♪ ♪
PHELAN ROBERT KRAFT IS DOING ALL
HE CAN TO HELP WITH COVID-19
RELATES.
STARTING ON APRIL THE PLANE WAS
SENT TO CHINA TO BRING BACK
MILLIONS OF MATH FOR AMERICAN
SERVING ON THE FRONT LINE.
THE FIGHT AGAINST COVID-19, SOME
OF THE MASS PURCHASE WENT
STRAIGHT TO THE EPICENTER OF THE
VIRUS TO POP UP THE HOSPITAL AT
THE JAVITS CENTER IN
NEW YORK CITY.
AND ALSO SOLD HIS PRIZE
SUPER BOWL LI RING FOR OVER
$1 MILLION AS PART OF
CORONAVIRUS AND FUND-RAISER.
HE JOINS US NOW.
A BEAUTIFUL RING.
THANKS FOR ALL YOU’VE DONE.
I WILL PUT UP ON THE SIDE ALL
YOU HAVE DONE.
THAT IS ONLY THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG.
THE RING IN PARTICULAR.
THAT HAD TO BE HARD TO GIVE UP
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT EASILY
OBTAINED.
I KNOW YOU HAVE A LOT OF THEM
BUT --
>> THAT ONE IS PRETTY SPECIAL.
YOU KNOW MY HAVE A GOOD FRIEND
MICHAEL RUBIN WHO STARTED THE
CHALLENGE AND HE WILL TRY TO
COME UP WITH COMPANY SPECIAL
THAT COULD GARNER A LOT OF
SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW, I THOUGHT ABOUT THE
SUPER BOWL WHEN WE WERE DOWN
28-3 WITH 2 MINUTES TO GO IN THE
THIRD PERIOD AND A CHANCE OF
WINNING THE GAME 99.6 TO LOSE.
WE CAME BACK AND IT WAS A GREAT
VICTORY.
IN SOME WAYS CAN MIGHT FEEL THE
MOOD FOR FIRE COUNTRY IS A
LITTLE DOWN NOW.
AND STILL THE GREATEST COUNTRY
IN THE WORLD.
WE WILL COME BACK AND SO I THINK
THAT RING A RING EPITOMIZE THAT.
AND I’M HAPPY TO SAY THAT A
PATRIOTS FAN WHO WANTS TO BE
ANONYMOUS RIGHT NOW, BUT I HOPE
THEY WILL COME PUBLIC WITH IT.
>> Sean: CAN WE OPEN STADIUM
SUCCESSFULLY?
I TALKED TO THE YANKEES IN SO
MANY DIFFERENT OWNERS.
PEOPLE GO THROUGH THESE
TURNSTILES TO TAKE TEMPERATURES.
IF YOU WANT TO GO TO THE GAME,
YOU HAVE TO WEAR A MASK, DRINK
YOUR BEER THROUGH A STRAW.
IT IS INCONVENIENT BUT YOU DO IT
FOR OTHER PEOPLE.
IS PROVEN SAFE IN NEW YORK FOR
THOSE WHO DID BUSINESS
DILIGENTLY.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> WE VERY MUCH ARE PREPARING TO
HOPEFULLY PLAY FOOTBALL THIS
FALL.
WE ARE WORKING HAND-IN-HAND WITH
OUR UNION.
WE BELIEVE WE ARE DEVELOPING
PROTOCOLS TO ALLOW US TO DO IT
IN A SAFE WAY.
AND OF COURSE, FOR THE PLAYERS
AND OUR PERSONNEL AND THEN OF
COURSE THE FANS.
BUT LUCKILY, WE CAN DO IT.
>> Sean: OKAY, TOM BRADY,
BELICHICK, BRADY, KRAFT ONE OF
THE BEST IN HISTORY.
CAN YOU COMMENT ON THAT?
>> WELL, I AM PRIVILEGED -- WE
ARE ABOUT TO GO TO OUR SECOND
CENTURY OF THE NFL.
I’M PLEASED TO HAVE THE GREATEST
QUARTERBACK IN THE HISTORY OF
THE LEAGUE IN THE FIRST 100
YEARS AND THE GREATEST COACH.
AND SO, IT IS A GREAT JOY TO
HAVE THIS PARTNERSHIP FOR 20
YEARS AND TO KEEP THEM TOGETHER.